salut comme tous les jours durant 32
jours cet été on se fait un petit jeu je
vous donne une énigme tous les jours et
le lendemain je vous donne la solution
donc aujourd'hui je commence par vous
donner la solution de l'énigme d'hier si
vous n'avez pas vu l'énigme d'hier stop
allez la voir tout de suite parce que là
je vais donner la réponse
alors je vous ai demandé pourquoi en
fait ma démonstration était fausse et un
moment donné elle est complètement
fausse elle serait pas fausse ci a ou b
n'était pas égal à 1
mais le fait que a et b soit ego fait
qu'il ya une erreur mathématique dans
mon processus
l'erreur à l'est entre la 6e et la 7e
étape quand je simplifie une dernière
fois en enlevant le multiplicateur à
moimbé de la gauche et de la droite pour
l'enlever ce multiplicateur à - b il
faudrait donc diviser la gauche est
divisée la droite parra - b est à - b ça
fait 1 - 1 est à -1 ça fait zéro et en
mathématiques on ne peut pas / 0 c'est
impossible
et j'en entends déjà qu'ils me disent
bah si c'est possible non c'est
impossible on peut diviser par un mais
pas par 06 je divise ce stylo en deux je
vais le casser en deux et je vais donner
une moitié à chacun ils auront 0,5 stylo
chacun si je divise ce stylo par une
personne je donne mon stylo donc il a
plus qu'un stylo mais si je divise ce
stylo par 0 il peut pas y avoir zéro
stylo il y en a forcément un au départ
donc je peux pas transformer ce stylo à
zéro en rien du tout on ne peut pas / 0
et c'est là où ma démonstration tient
pas la route et c'est pour ça que ça a
créé ce bug mathématiques qui fait qu'à
la fin on a deux égal 1 je pense que
tous ceux qui détestent les matches ont
kiffé cette énigme forcément mais elle
était assez anecdotique pour que je vous
la face et de toute manière a là rien à
voir avec l'énigme d'aujourd'hui pour la
9ème énigmes on a besoin d'accessoire ça
pourrait être des petits briquet mais ça
peut être aussi des piles on va le faire
avec des piles
parce qu'on ne veut pas fumer cet été
cette énigme et corporel vous devez
mettre les piles ou un briquet dans
chaque fourche de vos mains la fourche
étant la jonction entre le pouce et
l'index ici comme ceux ci un dans chaque
main et le défi oui parce qu on est
samedi j'ai dit que le samedi dès fois
je ferai des petits défis vous devez
partir de cette position et finir avec
cette pile ici dans cette position là et
cette pile ici dans cette position là
mais parce qu'il a toujours ah mais vous
ne devez toujours avoir qu'une seule
pile par main quand j'ai fait ça par
exemple c'était faux c'était pas bon
deuxième restriction lépine ne doivent
jamais se toucher sans trop choquer ou
se touchent et 3e restrictions et pas
des moindres on ne peut saisir la pile
qu'avec les pousser les index par
exemple vous ne pouvez pas faire
quelques
choses comme ça ça c'est pas le droit ça
c'est interdit comme je suis sympa je
vous fais quand même en mode très très
rapide donc elles sont bien dans la
position de départ là je passe ici elles
ne se sont pas touchées elles sont bien
entre le pouce et l'index et je les ai
quand même ses parts cherchez bien bon
courage si vous avez la solution vous
n'êtes pas dans les commentaires vous
pouvez en parler mais laissez les autres
chercher si vous trouvez vous mettez un
pouce en l'air ça nous servira de
compteurs pour savoir quel est le nombre
de personnes qui a réussi à résoudre
cette énigme la queue plus d'ailleurs un
défi qu une énigme passé un bon samedi
soir fait bien la fête si vous faites la
fête profiter du soleil s'il y en a là
où vous êtes passé plutôt un bel été
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la
chaîne le mental boxe et une vidéo par
jour pendant un an donc rendez vous
demain à 11h charm